remember before when I said Jerry
Seinfeld was banned from ever performing
at the comedy store that all changed a
few years back after new ownership took
over the store due to Mitzi Shore's
declining Health in 2018 Seinfeld
returned to the store for a surprise set
that still talked about to this day by
the comedians who were there to witness
Seinfeld told this story himself is from
his mouth he came back to the store
probably five years ago four years ago
he hadn't been in forever he told the
story he said the reason I hadn't been
in so long is Mitzi told me that
basically I wasn't good enough or wasn't
funny enough for this place and I just
toured and did other comedy elsewhere
and then he got the show okay Seinfeld
became a massive hit one of the biggest
arguably the biggest comedy hit in the
history of Television yeah and they used
to have a house on King's Road where
Mitzi lives right yeah and Jerry bought
a house above their house literally and
he said every day he would drive in one
of his Porsches down to CBS Radford yeah
and he would slow down on purpose to see
if any of the shores were outside yeah
to say hello to let them know I'm just